hey Vsauce is Lacey and today I'm here
with some great news we've introduced a
new member to our Vsauce family although
what you really call us a family I think
we're more of a collection like a team
like those people I don't get chosen for
dodgeball if you love nerds as much as I
do you'll certainly love black nerd
comedy check it out
fine I'm Andre and I'm a black nerd now
I am not gay
even though many people think that I am
like my mom but if I was gay I know the
exact man I would marry Super Mario no
the following performance is to make you
laugh enough for me to be on American
Idol remember I'm a comedian first in a
singer second and by second I mean ever
Mario one two three world RPG hey Mario
no Mario I'll get four players do SFP we
follow you through your Mario Galaxy hey
Mario 64 Mario
Mario you go that I play you did
everyday you beat my Super Mario romance
I love you when you're wearing blue or
red pants I got a Super Mario romance
I love all thank you when you used to
dance dance I got a Super Mario Roman
mário romance
Mario Bros and now it's time for
breakdown I'll be now sir
Cooper leads with plow stars blushes
positive he weeks
hooba
love war
but now waluigi i waluigi
oh but I digress I got a super barrio
grow bed I'll play all eight world
sleeps a princess I got a super mario
romance
play Mario Kart integers I got a super
money
romance
barrio man
re-arose
Oh Mario Oh judge see I even got a Super
Mario Brothers movie action figure
that's how real this Super Mario
bromance is thank you so much for
watching this video I did a lady Gaga
parody no one's ever done that on
youtube before original if you want the
extended version plus video blog you'll
have to go to my channel you'll get more
of the girl I do sketches spoofs video
blogs retro nerdy and lovely pop culture
that I love so much I even have a giant
Smurf collection I'm for real about that
so check me out on my channel
youtube.com slash black merit company to
watch all my videos and you can see me
here on Vsauce from time to time as well
I'm going over there right now and I
hope to see you there when you get there
all right I'm doing this chair won't
move fast enough